some people are gravely worried about
the uncertainty and the negative
potential associated with transhumans
superhuman AGI and indeed we are
stepping into a great unknown realm it's
almost like a rock the hot type of thing
really having we fundamentally don't
know what a superhuman AI is gonna do
and that's the truth of it right and
then if you tend to be an optimist you
will focus on the good possibilities if
you tend to be a worried person who's
pessimistic you'll focus on on the bad
possibilities if you tend to be a
Hollywood movie maker you focus on scary
possibilities maybe with a happy ending
because because that's what sells movies
we don't we don't know what's gonna
happen I do think however this is the
situation humanity has been in for a
very long time when the cavemen stepped
out of their caves and began agriculture
we really had no idea that was gonna
lead to cities in space flight and so
forth and when the first early humans
created language to carry out simple
communication about the moose they had
just killed over there they did not
envision Facebook differential calculus
and MC Hammer I don't know all the rest
right I mean there's so much that is has
come about out of early inventions which
humans couldn't have ever foreseen and I
think we're just in the same situation I
mean the invention of language or
civilization could have led to
everyone's death right hence and the way
it's still could and the creation of
superhuman AI it could kill everyone and
I don't I don't want it to over almost
almost none of us do of course the way
we got to this point as a species and a
culture has been to keep doing amazing
new things that
didn't fully understand and that's what
we're gonna keep on doing Nick Bostrom's
book was influential but I felt that in
some ways it was a bit deceptive the way
he phrased things if he read his precise
philosophical arguments which are very
logically drawn what both Sturm says in
his book super intelligence is that we
cannot rule out the possibility that the
super intelligence will do some very bad
things and that's true on the other hand
some of the associated rhetoric makes it
sound like it's very likely his super
intelligence will do these bad things
and if you follow his philosophical
arguments closely he doesn't show that
what he just shows is that that you
can't rule it out and we don't know
what's going on I don't think Nick
Bostrom or anyone else is gonna stop the
human race from developing advanced AI
because it's a source of tremendous
intellectual curiosity but also of
tremendous economic advantage so if
let's say President Trump decided to ban
artificial intelligence research I don't
think he's going to but suppose he did
China will keep doing artificial
intelligence research if US and China
Bennet you know Africa will do it
everywhere around the world has AI
textbooks and computers and everyone now
knows you can make people's lives better
and make money from developing more
advanced AI so there's no possibility in
practice to halt in our development what
we can do is try to direct it in the
most beneficial direction according to
our our best judgment and that that's
part of what leads me to pursue AGI via
an open-source project such as OpenCog I
respect very much what Google Baidu
Facebook Microsoft and these other big
companies are doing in AI there's many
good people they're doing good research
and with good hearted motivations but I
guess I'm enough of an old leftist
raised by socialists and I sort of I'm
skeptical that the company whose main
motive is to maximize shareholder value
is really going to do the best thing for
the human race if they create a human
level and I I mean they might on the
other hand there's a lot of other
motivations there the public company in
the end has a fiduciary responsibility
to their their shareholders all in all I
think the odds are better if AI is
developed in a way that is owned by the
whole human race and can be developed by
all of humanity for for its own good and
open source software is sort of the
closest approximation that we have to
that now so our our aspiration is to
grow OpenCog into sort of the the Linux
of AGI and have people all around the
world developing it to serve their own
local needs and putting their own values
and understanding into it as it becomes
more and more intelligent certainly this
doesn't give us any guarantee we can
observe things like you know Linux has
fewer bugs then Windows or OSX and it's
open source so more more eyeballs on
something sometimes can make it more
reliable but there's no solid guarantee
that making an AGI open source will make
the singularity come out well but my gut
feel is that there's enough hard
problems with creating a superhuman AI
and having it respect human values and
have a relationship of empathy with
people as it grows there's enough
problems there without the young AGI
getting wrapped up in competition of
country versus country and and company
versus company and internal politics
within companies or militaries I feel
like we don't want to add these problems
of sort of human / primate social status
competition dynamics we don't want to
add those problems into the challenges
that that are faced in in Ag our
development
[Music]